anh
alo
alo chào bạn
thế
nhưng còn 2 phút tâm sự anh tranh thủ
cho mọi người xem cái video này ạ
Ừ Vậy giờ 5 phút
Hữu được một hình thức giải trí Châu
Tinh Trì mà
ông áo
khi sex
ạ bây giờ vui thì nói cho bạn nghe xem
đây
mình cực kỳ luôn
hôm nay sẽ chấm ra tâm sự làm thế
ai để mình kim cái này
em xinh xinh gái xinh tươi trong danh
sách
để bắt đầu xem nhé
[âm nhạc]
tôi lại đâu thử dành ta coi
cũng là con gái đó đặt địa chỉ một người
nhỏ bé nhất giờ đây đối với anh ta nghe
mà chỉ người khác vậy là sẽ chết thôi
ii-chuẩn bị
ở đâu ạ
Thế
nhưng là nhiều nhà trai vậy đâu đi
ơi à
à à
[Vỗ tay]
ừ ừ
Ê Cảm ơn nhiều nha
[âm nhạc]
em Em And I
chị
sẽ đi tôi đâu vậy
Em biết sao nữa đi
anh làm cái gì đi
vắng mà
hình ảnh
ở đâu mà
dậy đi à
anh em cảm thấy hình như là được bao
nhiêu lâu lắm Trời ảnh của một cảm giác
giống gì
anh đem nó thì trên nghe nha em rất là
thế mạnh
Ừ anh biết
khi bé nó thì trong nghe nha Anh đâu có
cần thị đâu
nó cản trở mà
khi
nói về tôi đè nha à
Ê hồi nãy nói gì
không Có gì chủ đề đó anh hỏi em là có
biết một người tên là Mai trên không
Ừ cô bạn này tập 90
Em không quen Không quen bạn có chuyện
nữa trong công viên
Mai chen đó
mày chưa thì có khi đi chơi đêm cũng
quen nhưng mà không ngoan bay trên
Ơ sao lại gì có bạn đã quên không suy
nghĩ kỹ đi chuyện gì quan trọng anh lắm
Em nghĩ chắc chị Hai quen ta thứ Vậy thì
chỉ có đi
[âm nhạc]
để toàn chính tạo được một lòng à
ừ ừ
Có
ai đi chơi được 26 tuổi đi ngoài có sao
không không sao
chỉ có một người tên là Mai trên không
Mà trên phải em nói đi ai làm mai cho em
chứ mày cho này đây nè
ý
là cái Trần thuốc vô trà lúc rảnh chứ
anh ta đổi dành chút Nhút Nhát một tuần
lễ 4 ngày không tới nhà trường khi Voice
lại ngủ như vậy nè vậy sao bình thường
nên ta có hoạt động gì không Nếu có hoạt
động thì làm sao gọi là dù chứ chút vui
nè Chúc cho buổi tối đó biết chưa hả đây
đi chữa
ở Pháp
trò chơi bắn đi hôm nay dù sao cũng được
Ừ anh ấy là thôi đi anh ấy còn đang quay
lại cái đầu của bọn trẻ em mình đâu khi
nhớ đến làm xôi đã xem cùng với buồn quá
vậy chứ tự tử
xe tải trò chơi thử qua em có cái gì Mày
thử đi thử sao mình không cần được con
nhất ở đâu thông tin là thử đi Thôi mà
đừng có trả lời đâu có ai chứ tôi đi mà
không một lần thôi Ok Chị đừng nói không
được à mà đi đưa đây
Bộ
Công an chứ nhớ mặc gì không nhắn thử
nhận cái thế đi chơi à
à à
Em
đang làm gì vậy ạ
anh
em có biên chế không phải chết rồi hết
ấy đó rồi
Nó kia nó cứ
cho mình cái mình đặt tay sao hả Đã nó
còn anh với những cô con bé được thử này
nha Sau này muốn muốn thử nữa thì bị chỉ
mang đó biết chưa hỏi con sẽ thích thôi
à Sợ chứ nhưng mà làm gì em
alo
hi vọng vừa rồi mày ông xem không Cái cú
để đánh gậy thôi
Nếu kê bảo ở đúng như tôi đã dậy vợ
không nhớ tôi đã dậy thì cơ à Ừ nhưng mà
từ video vừa rồi thì đúc kết được một
cái
chắc là giống như tội thứ đã từng nói gì
vậy Nói thứ nhất để con gái chủ động thứ
hai là gì
thì mình cứ thoải mái tự nhiên nó ô
ngoài rất là thoải mái tự nhiên à
Ê bà con địt nhau
Anh thường chỉ có mấy Hãy cho tôi thôi
đến nay chủ động
Ừ
ông này có nói lại là anh thích em đâu
đứa nãy tỏ tình nỗi nhớ vẫn không nhiều
vẫn có nói gì cả cũng trả lời Cái thứ
như làm hay sao Nếu bạn chọn làm thế nào
để em mới thích trước thì thực ra thì
cũng đầu video đấy chứng tỏ ông ấy chứng
tỏ kiểu mình hiểu cậu dạng là lạnh lùng
lạnh lùng bo hiểu cái rồi lại giỏi hơn
em đấy ở cái khoản anh đấy ngưỡng mộ
em đầy ngưỡng mộ thì thực ra hồi trước ở
tôi Bạn gái thất bại phải nhiều
Tôi thức sau đó gì mai mà cái thời muốn
tôi đi làm thầy này thật cái vẻ thành
công hơn với nhiều bạn muốn ngưỡng mộ
hơn kết hợp việc là mình học Dân công
nghệ thường tin thì nhiều bạn cảm thấy
nó rất là ngầu đặc biệt thời đại hiện
đại giờ ông hiểu ông chỉ cần làm vài
thao tác kiểu làm tôn chạy tự động phẫn
nộ em ấy nhưng em mới thấy ngầu cả mọi
thứ đều lấy chứng nhận hãy trở thế
nếu mà thực ra là nó cũng có đôi khi nó
phản lại giống kiểu ấy có vài em chỉ sợ
tôi có thể hack cái nick em lấy em về cứ
Rõ hoàn toàn à
10 sự thật đó là
Ừ
cái này chia sẻ mày ông con trai thôi đó
là chờ thôi mà tôi đi tán bạn nữ đến nhờ
nhỏ ăn là tuổi hơn có cái ăn kia có cả
lớp 12 của để tôi năm nhất năm hai thì
tán em lớp 12 chẳng thấy say đấy nhưng
mà ở
mấy em đấy Có vậy là
nó nghỉ vẫn còn hơi mộng mơ em đợi Nói
chung là hồi đấy không tán được em đấy
gửi em mới thích một anh biết rap hơn
một anh có sự nghiệp ổn định
nguồn anh là thầy chẳng là gì trong mắt
em đấy à hơi buồn à
khi chia tay là nói hack nick Thế nên
cuối cùng người tao yêu mày đâu thì
tránh chia tay đúng không ạ sợ
em mắc gái à em bé gái nhưng ai vẫn thấy
con gà đúng không em đã gái mà em vẫn
thích con gái như em sẽ chọn đối tượng
giả sử như thằng sinh viên của tôi này
nó còn hướng nó xác định rõ là việc là
nó không hiểu được thì nó sẽ đi tìm sẽ
cố kiếm những bạn gái dù động Chẳng sao
là ngoạn nhìn thấy quan trọng là với bạn
gái chủ động thì ông ông thì ông lại
phải đã tưởng nó cần gì thằng con trai
bị động không ạ Rồi cần cái gì cũng đều
không thể biến thành lạnh lùng boy được
đã ông sẽ biến thành cái gì
nhiều nhiều bạn gái được ra thích có
ông ông phải hiểu nhé này nó là giống gì
nữa
Ừ cái thứ hơn những cảm thịt Mẹ tôi là
một ngày hôm sau đó
thì nếu bạn gái thích kiểu rằng là đắt
đi giờ ngăn kéo dài là thích một người
một người con trai khá giống bố mình
phải dùng từ như thế Tại sao em thấy một
người thì sẽ trợ cho mình và lo lắng cho
mình luôn Vân
trưởng thành cứ nhưng mà ngược lại thì
có nhiều bạn lại kiểu thích chăm sóc
người khác kiểu dạng là như chị gái
không dùng thường Mẹ hư quá mâm đi tôi
không có mì hơi quá Nhưng mà nó giống
kiểu chị gái thì lại hướng đến có một
đứa em trai nghe lời ngoan ngoãn nhản
trông kiểu trắng trẻo bụ bẫm và nhắn tôi
từng tôi từng à A Gọi dùng từng lái máy
bay đúng đúng nghĩa thế đấy có một người
ở
cô có một người chồng cũng cũng như kìa
chị gái tôi đấy à thực ra là hiện tại
thì thôi vẫn đang lái máy bay mà Bởi vì
bạn bạn nhà tôi hơn 1 tuổi
Ừ nhưng mà không ngờ bạn nhà tôi theo
trường phái đó trẻ con Thành A tôi vẫn
này chân thành chứ không được cưng chiều
nhiều lắm
như con gái đôi khi rất thích Cưng Chiều
thằng anh trai vì
nếu mà ông yêu hơn một tuổi thôi thôi
thầm thì yêu bằng tuổi
con này có cái gì đó luôn coi mấy thằng
con trai bằng tuổi nó nhỏ bé hơn không
thực Thạch Thế nên con gái thích một là
yêu lớn tuổi 21 khi yêu cùng tội hay nhỏ
tuổi hơn như thế nữa họ sẽ coi ông như
em trai ông ạ
Ừ cái này thì để các bạn nữ sẽ tự vào để
mà
nói xem tôi là đúng hay sai chứ tôi tôi
đúc kết được một cái thôi
Ừ tôi không không đánh đông được tất cả
Em mà tôi đúc kết được thế
à à
Ừ tự nhiên cách mình bắt đầu chuyển
hướng khác thứ gì đó nó cứ thế nào nhỉ
không thích nó lành mạnh không
Ok hơi từ trường lại và á Nhớ Bộ hôm nay
buổi tâm sự với tâm sự đây sẽ nói chung
là một cuối tuần mà các bạn cứ giãn đi
tâm sự rất nhiều cái không ạ
Tâm sự về đồ án tâm sự về công việc
liên quan đến ngành một tí không em tin
một tí có thứ tâm sự khó khăn được ra
vẫn được mình sẽ giải đáp và Trả Lời Mọi
Câu hỏi hôm nay
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Ông kia nói đúng vậy thôi
Kinh Nghiệm Chia Tay rất nhiều lần II
ở đầu tiên trả lời câu hỏi là
Ừ
anh Có code tool Tôi không biết đọc cái
này như thế nào nhưng mà tôi từng ngày
qua mấy cái vụ này Ờ Cái này nó là giống
như nếu mà tôi tôi tôi không biết bên
này lắm hình như nó chuyển nó là một cái
hình thức gì đó Kiếm tiền gì gì đó
và dẫn kiểu dân
dân bit mà giật Coi kiểu Huế
Em ngỡ là một cái dân gì đó để kiếm tiền
thôi nhớ không phải bảo để dẫn coi nhưng
mà tôi không rõ về cái vụ này là chính
vì việc nói tôi không rõ vụ này tất cả
chị tôi không chứa chắc chắn ai chưa
từng làm tôm mấy vụ này rồi nhớ à Cái
này tôi muốn nói chung ngoài việc là ở
nếu mà các bạn thấy tôi tưởng là mì tôm
Facebook đồng bọn mày thật cao có bóng
vàng cái tu nữa rồi nhưng mà tôi làm
tung đấy nó giận thế thôi còn chạy hộ
cho mày ra nếu người ta gửi người ta
Người ta không biết xài Vân thì thôi sẽ
hỗ trợ người ta rất nhiều cái phạm trở
lại teamview qua thì Chốt rồi các thứ
không biết người ta có dùng thì cốt để
kinh doanh không nghe Mà thôi không quan
tâm người ấy em chỉ tôi làm mục đích kìa
chia sẻ giúp đỡ và kiểu nói chung là để
cải thiện năng lực bản thân đây nữa Nói
Vân đôi bên cùng có lợi không ạ em quan
trọng là cái lợi của tôi đem lại thì gần
như à à có được sự tin những thực phẩm
này đang cả người ta cảm ơn rồi Cá thứ
ra về sau người ta đô thị quên mình lấy
nhau mà
mình không quan trọng vì người ta nhớ
thì người ta đắp chả cái gì cả cái này
ra là tôi thích làm khổ thế
đấy có một ý thức của tôi cứ cho lần
tinh thần cả tự tình nguyện là tình
nguyện từ thiện có gì đó đây
cho tôi tôi không làm tôi không làm cái
mục đích kiếm tiền bằng mình cái này nên
thành ra là à
anh không tìm hiểu về mấy cái mảnh này
giống như nhiều Ông hỏi tôi với coi hay
hỏi tôi về góc chen Vân không tìm hiểu
mấy mảnh đấy nữa bởi vì tôi biết thì
biết bởi dân công nghệ mà không biết thì
hơi sai nhưng mà tôi không sẽ không làm
bạn mình rồi đấy ạ
Ừ Ok bạn kia vừa hỏi về cả Chắc cũng cả
đây à Mình mạnh được cả hai cái đấy chắc
mình hỗ trợ được
Ừ có gì chị ạ tầm 10 giờ sau 10 giờ các
bạn à Nhắn tin inbox mình cũng được
ừ ừ
Em thấy hay chơi nhân thuận bài gì á
tôi chơi game
anh có hai cách chơi game
chơi game nhân phẩm đúng nghĩa là tôi
gọi nó nhân vật cho vui hoa cả chơi game
đấy thôi thường ai chơi bài theo kiểu nó
dị một tí gây khó chịu chứ không chơi
mày cái bài mà chỉ để thắng Nói chung là
tôi chơi game nhân phẩm thì không phải
mục đích để khám Chơi bài ăn tiện Thế
thì ăn tiền nhưng mà tội không mục đích
tháng cho vui thôi cứ
Còn nếu mà chơi game heo cậu để mà có
còn ý thức thứ hai của tôi chơi game
không phải để vui mà chơi game để thắng
thắng thì mới vui rồi ta hay à Buổi trưa
giờ lời em ạ Mẹ tôi sẽ cố hết sức có thể
và tôi sẽ cậu thường thấy kiếm mấy cái
game mà có động não không lý mà toàn nói
chung nhà hoặc cá sẽ rồi cũng có sẽ
không có nó có chiến thuật và nó khảo
luyện cho mình lúc đấy thì sẽ chơi với
tinh thần thoải mái bởi vì là không động
não Chơi game bắn súng rồi ừ ừ
ừ ừ
anh
đi phỏng vấn gặp câu vì sao tôi nên chọn
bạn thì nên trả lời sao Ờ
mình thì từng xem Khánh khá nhiều cái
video trên mạng nói gần đây này rồi Có
khi là bạn cũng xem đây rồi và mình thì
chưa cờ bị dính con này bởi vì thường
người ta ạ hỏi con này khi mà người ta
đã có nhiều lựa chọn khác cũng kiểu tầm
tầm bạn hoặc thận thấy ổn hơn để hỏi có
lại một câu hỏi vớt chứ không phải là
một câu hỏi ngay từ đầu Hỏi nếu một khi
người đã từ đầu hỏi thì K thì như đã nói
họ vẫn có quá nhiều lựa chọn khác thế
nên là họ sẽ đánh giá bạn có câu hỏi này
thì Nếu giả sử của mình được Hỏi như câu
này nhá đầu tiên là theo ý mình trả lời
thì đó là mình sẽ nói ra cái thế mạnh
của mình thế mạnh ở đây không phải thế
mạnh về à Anh chuyên ngành tôi sẽ nói
như thế này đó là em ở con người đào J5
em à
em có hình ảnh đó ra nhiều mạng chứ em
thì chuyên kiểu futech nhưng mà em vẫn
thể nhảy sang được cả những màn khác và
hỗ trợ cho bên vận hành 2 hỗ trợ ở bên
marketing vân vân trú nhà
mình theo cửa xếp đặt bông mình ngồi đấy
được mình cái gì Bị chiến lược kiểu thế
à Còn nếu mất giờ sự bạn mà được đặt câu
hỏi như thế thì cứ nhờ bạn như như đã
nói bạn không nên nói lại những cái
cái buổi phỏng vấn nhá đây tôi không
biết dùng hỏi bạn chưa nghe lời nhắc lại
một lần nữa các bạn khi đi phỏng vấn nhá
các bạn thứ nhất là mặc ăn mặc thời sự
không nói gì này Ờ
nói chung và mọi thứ chỉnh tề lịch sự
này Thứ hai là các bạn nên in cái CP các
bạn là
cái gọi là Ji Sung thì chúng hơn không
phải seev cev đấy với smack đấy các bạn
I nào ra cứ việc các bạn
tuy có thể nhà phỏng vấn đang cần thế à
Đang đọc nói chuyện máy tính với vợ nhớ
bạn nên in 4 rồi tôi đưa cho họ cái cái
lúc mà đi phỏng vấn đề làm gì họ không
cần nhìn chăm chăm mà mặt bạn các bạn
bối rối mà thực ra và đôi khi họ quên
mất trong seri các bạn là biết gì nên
đưa cho họ để họ có thứ cần mà đọc
Ừ lúc đấy để làm gì nữa để người ra
không hỏi lại những cái có trên phí vì
các bạn buổi phỏng vấn đấy hạn chế nó
những cái đã biết ở trong sim gì cơ ạ
anh đã biết rồi thì họ đọc rồi mày không
ạ thận họ hoặc họ thậm chí ở chưa đọc
nhưng mà để lúc họ đọc và họ sẽ hỏi
những câu khác họ họ sẽ chỉ hỏi những
con xung quanh cái CV các bạn thôi hạn
chế giờ họ hỏi lan man quá nhiều cái các
bạn không để mà các bạn hạn chế tránh
cái việc nói câu tôi không biết bởi vì
họ sẽ cộng Họ sẽ không hỏi làm An đấy
thì cái câu mà tôi nên chọn bạn thì đấy
các bạn sẽ nói những thế mạnh khác của
các bạn mà các bạn không ghi ở trong
tivi thế thôi
khi mà Zen tô mình từng phiên sinh viên
mình không nên cốt magento 2 ở Glass 2
đi làm được tập liên quan này bởi vì em
mình dậy sinh viên mình razzil và Phú
Quốc Thì
cái này nó nó không áp dụng của Basel
đúng không ạ Và cốt của nó lại kiểu
à mình khó chịu theo kiểu là cốc cả đầy
nó bị hướng theo đủ Mỗi cái đấy thôi nó
không nó không kiểu nếu mà các bạn có
khi hiểm cái đấy mà quan hệ sẵn người
khác thì các bạn phải học lại từ đầu
mình không thích kiểu đấy Mình thích cho
sinh viên mình hồi đi thực tập thì mình
lên một là sau Trung Quốc ở đó
ở Hà Nội nổi lúc nào đấy không đấy hai
người sang ngôn ngữ khác tôi Tôi chỉ
thích sinh viên tôi sẽ thế thôi chứ đừng
có cố cậu web Hà
Mai lên tô
các bạn nữ cùng tuổi có chiều bạn nào
cũng Tuổi không Nếu với nhau bạn nữa
không tuổi ở luôn luôn coi ông là em
thấy nữa là thứ nhất là nó sẽ có tí bao
thủ tôi gặp tất cả luôn
Ừ từ trước cái này toàn thế đó là nó sẽ
coi luôn là em nên thành nào thì bảo thủ
với ông nên thành ra là một là ông biến
thành ông Thành Phố Dưới Hai ông phải
thể hiện cái độ cảm nhận nam tính của
Vậy là nát rồi Bạn ấy còn nếu mà ông
muốn chiều thì đấy nó coi ông mà em thì
ông cứ biến anh em thật rồi đó chị em
Anh vừa đi học vừa đi làm thì làm sao để
cân bằng cả hai à
Ừ cái này thơm luôn là khó thừa do mà
khuấy cho tôi cân bằng giờ cân bằng thời
gian đi chơi lại thì ông phải rút gọn
thời gian ngủ anh lại cái thứ nhất Nhưng
mà thực ra lấy hại sức Vậy thế nên là
thực ra là cân bằng thời gian về một
chuyện cân bằng việc là ông chủ tâm là
một thứ nó hơi khó thế nên mà
ông nên đi làm thì đó đúng là anh thì nó
sẽ đỡ hơn
à à
ở siêu nhân toàn thì tôi không thua thì
thua thì vẫn vui mà miễn là tôi ra được
bài Thôi tôi chỉ cay kem bài lừa rồi
ờ ờ các bạn hỏi mình về tài liệu thì
mình không rõ luôn nhé bởi vì à tài liệu
những ở trên mạng thôi có vài tài liệu
nào mà mình chưa xài được mình sẽ chia
sẻ thôi à
có việc đi làm sớm để chấp nhận CPA cpi
là gì nhỉ lửa lương phụ cấp nhà ở
a cpi
I
stand Bone là viết tắt của gì này
thế kỷ niệm
thiết kế toán chúng Ôi cái Kế toán à
a cpi
em không có đi không vậy trời ý bạn ấy
là lương thì vậy
đi làm sớm chấp nhận việc phụ cấp thấp
Chắc thế hay tập trung trên trường để ờ
khi
được gpa
ở nhà không biết làm gì luôn Ờ
có điểm trung bình tích lũy những
Em nghe chị nói là gì nhỉ
Ừ cái này cả quà kỷ niệm đúng không
tưởng là lương chứ
khi nghe đại khái Nếu là lương thì mình
cái ngành này thì bắt buộc phải có nhiều
kinh nghiệm đã nó kêu không chỉ mỗi lý
thuyết Nên là các bạn nên thực hành
nhiều
một ngày mày lúc đầu năm đầu hay là năm
thứ hai nữa Nếu không chấp nhận không
được được rồi từng nói rồi
rồi Những năm sau bứt phá lương cao hơn
thoải mái ừ
ở hả người đốt cháo đứa cháu là sao
Ý tao là gồm cái gì ạ tao nó Facebook
của TP
khóa xong mình dậy các bạn thì các bạn
với hình dung được Việt Trung Quốc
Ẩm
Thực tập thì có yêu cầu gì nhiều không
trong ngành này thì thực tập các bạn nếu
mà các bạn lại việc không đỗ phỏng vấn
các bạn cứ bảo là em muốn được tập có
lương hay cái gì đó Ờ
Ừ nên thế để mà
a cho à
khi người ta hoàn toàn tuyển các bạn
những và ông phải nói thêm mà em sẽ cam
kết khi mà thực tập xong em sẽ làm ở
công ty một năm hai năm trở lại đây thì
người ta hoàn toàn là kiểu người ta sẽ
chuyển các bạn và sẽ sẽ hiểu gần như là
người ta thoải mái các bạn bởi vì ở rất
nhiều công ty sợ đào tạo ông Xong rồi
ông nhảy không nhận việc ông chỉ cần nói
hai cái đấy thôi là coi như là ông hoàn
toàn được tươi
số điểm tích lũy tôi không thể học nên
là tôi không biết nhưng mà
Anh ở cũng chính vì tôi không Thi ạ
Không biết trả lời câu này như thế nào
xin hoãn việc học để làm để luôn là một
câu hỏi khó nếu mà nếu mà các bạn học
nghề Giống như mình thì sẽ là học nghề
mục đích để đi làm mà hẹn ra là các bạn
cứ
không quan trọng với bằng cấp không quan
trọng việc tốt nghiệp nghề đấy không có
bạn đi làm rồi các bạn thành công rồi
đúng không ạ Còn các bạn học đại học các
bạn để xác định cái bằng hai vân vân tự
nhiên à và các bạn muốn có cái bằng về
lâu về dài nữa chị các bạn cứ có thể vẫn
học mà có thể nói với Giáo viên thứ gà
không biết mấy ông thế nào nhưng mà từ
hồi càng lớn lên đấy thì tôi lại quan
điểm
ở khá gần gũi giáo viên hơn tất cả giáo
viên đều quý rồi và tôi toàn không hẳn
đã tâm sự như tôi thường hay cậu nói
riêng nói chuyện riêng của các giáo viên
đã ghép ở
không phải đi cửa sau nhé Không phải đi
hối Nội cả tính Tôi là con đêm chính
không làm mấy giờ đây em còn tội nói
thẳng và tôi coi họ như kiểu những người
tiền bối đi trước thôi là những và mình
cứ chia sẻ rất thoải mái xem họ kiểu có
giúp đỡ rồi của mình hay kiểu hỗ trợ
mình được cái gì không Vân Vân
ở trong là giáo viên cũng mọi người
nhưng nếu mình cứ coi như thế thì mình
nói chuyện rất là thoải mái và
họ sẽ giúp đỡ mình Họ không hẳn là thiên
vị mình đâu họ còn thích những cái sinh
viên nào đó mà kiểu cởi mở khi họ - nói
giúp và đương nhiên vẫn có nhiều giáo
viên khác khai và cố rạch ròi cái ranh
giới nhưng mà đa số Tôi đã từng gặp
giảng viên thì
thoải mái
3 - giáo viên mà Nguồn ông hối lộ không
nói gì ngoài Đông đút lót thì thôi chịu
nhưng mà còn còn không thì sẽ là những
giờ viên là kiểu muốn hiểu sinh viên là
sôi sinh viên có vấn đề thì ra họ cũng
từng trải rồi nó họ sẽ thoải mái thôi
thế hả mình được tuyển thẳng mà từ trước
là mình phỏng vấn nó toàn phỏng vấn chưa
có mà còn từ tháng thôi
từ hôm nay không học đâu hôm nay sẽ chấm
đồ án và tâm sự thôi thế này là tôi mới
tâm sự thì lúc này không Mày không học
gì cả Không ai không kiến thức mới Nếu
đọc đọc tiêu đề rồi mà nó không
à à
em
yên tâm hypixel mà biết về Facebook thì
có lợi thế Nhiều không Cái này thì
cái này là thứ cái là nó yêu cầu chung
thôi Đó là kiểu Nếu một lập trình viên
có kinh nghiệm thì bắt buộc phải biết
Facebook này biết Lập trình hướng đối
tượng này ở chỗ mà mình cái đấy là cơ
bản rồi
bài hát node.js về pp nó không đi đôi
với nhau đâu Nên là các bạn sẽ trở nên
chọn một trong hai cái thôi
hôm nay hì a mình nay thì có nhiều bạn à
bảo vệ đồ án đợt 2 có thể vào xem nhưng
mà thực ra thì mình sẽ tạo chỉ chấm nhận
cái nhóm má đoán đợt 1 vào đây các thử
còn những cái nhóm mà kiểu nhóm sau đấy
thì mình sẽ chấm riêng buổi ngày mai sau
nhé Mai cho mình chấm thủ công bình
thường không có livestream gì cả à
Ê bà Mai mình sẽ chia lại một vài nhóm
sao
và lẫn cả là chắc là mai mai thì cho
mình mấy hai ngày mai tôi thi Tôi đang
thi liên thông nên thành ra là
à À không không không rảnh lắm Nếu mà
nếu thế giới tuần sau tuần sau thì tôi
sẽ lại livestream cốt gọi like code
không ạ vào chủ nhật tuần sau nhé Chiều
chủ nhật tuần sau làm về
con chatbot cho trình YouTube này tôi
tôi sẽ thử tìm hiểu xem làm được không ạ
Tôi thấy nhiều người làm rồi sẽ làm dễ
thôi mà thích hợp với về tôi sẽ làm các
Pác Bó để làm gì để mà trả lời cho mình
câu hỏi mà nhiều ông thường hay hỏi thôi
chồng nhớ nhiều nhiều bạn chắc là kiểu
thấy Facebook YouTube để sót nên vào Lần
đầu tiên xem ấy thì mấy bạn ấy toàn hỏi
tôi là kiểu Anh học trường nào Anh sinh
năm bao nhiêu và những câu hỏi mà Thành
phổ biến rồi đấy những cái câu hoàn toàn
thậm chí à tại sao anh không dùng ghét
cô chẳng hạn hết ấy hỏi những câu đấy
thì mình sẽ dùng con chắt bóp không cho
mình chưa biết về y nên mình không anh
bóp để học được về mà trả lời những câu
phức tạp thì mình sẽ chỉ nhận diện được
trong nha trong câu hỏi có cái chữ gì
thì mình bắt theo cái từ khóa đấy để mà
trả lời thôi còn ông nằm ở lươn lẹo hơn
đâu mà lách từ học kỳ hỡi chịu cái cái
thế
nên là tí các bạn thích thì các bạn cũng
hỏi mình một vài câu hỏi để mình cảm
thấy câu nào mà mình nhận thấy nó phổ
biến ở mình sẽ đưa tuần sau mình sẽ có
con check pass cho các bạn để mà khẩu
các bạn hỏi cái lập tức con theo bóp trả
lời thế trong thế cái kênh lập trình
mình chúng phải chuyên nghiệp hơn đúng
không ạ
Ừ ông địa hỏi lại câu hợp với không dùng
ghế cô đấy tôi gần đây rồi một bắt đầu
đang có ý định dùng ai vì thấy nó tích
hợp nhiều vãi mà đã cả cái kênh YouTube
của thằng với cô đi nó xin nói nào chia
sẻ rất nhiều cái hay nếu mày ông để kỹ
là mấy hôm trước thôi tôi chia sẻ về cái
mẹo về lập trình từ cái kênh vẽ cô đấy
chứ Đấy con kênh của thằng Jack lane đều
kính Hùng nó chỉ đang mấy cái thông báo
ở biểu bản cập nhật này mà cập nhật này
có gì mới
hỗ trợ thế nó Chẳng chăm sóc với kênh
YouTube của nó đang những cái liên quan
công nghệ thông tin gì cả Sao 1-piece
tôm thế này ra tôi bắt đầu nghĩ à
xe hơi sang
a cho luvias code miễn phí mà nó ngon
Face Thằng t tôm mà mất phí
em à Có những loại bằng xong rồi vị GTA
để nó xem nhận bằng gì à
thực ra thì các bạn không cần lên có
bằng giỏi hay bằng xuất sắc đâu vì mày
cái đấy làm cho người tuyển các bạn thì
là thứ nhất là người ta thì không quan
tâm thứ hai người ra một con tâm thì nó
ý kỹ cái người ta đôi khi đòi hỏi đó hỏi
các bạn và yêu cầu các bạn có gì đó cao
quá ấy nói chung là đừng làm như là kỳ
vọng nhiều người Ông mấy ông vừa vào
không nên nổ đừng có thể hiện mình quá
giỏi chứ Khi ông tự tin giỏi thật không
thì à Cứ bằng Khánh rồi được rồi bằng
yếu thì nghe hát quá đây là thôi Bất là
cân nhắc mua xe với cái thực sự ông như
nào nó rậm Rì uống này bằng yếu ở ông
keo ông đi thực tập nhiều rồi ông kiểu
không học hành gì cũng được không sao
à à
Anh
biết mỗi hướng sự kiện à
ở dưới bạn phải học thêm thôi Nói chung
người yêu cầu khi yêu cầu tiêu chuẩn của
lập trình viên nên biết qua những cái
kiểu về Facebook này mô hình mvc và các
thứ
à hóa sau mình sẽ dậy nhưng mà chỉ dậy
một cách tương đối cho các bạn biết thôi
không đưa ngờ không thể làm dạy hết được
là một mảnh cả thế công nhận là nó bị lý
thuyết vào đau lão ấy đi chính mình cũng
còn không làm chủ được nó thế nên là
mình không thể dạy các bạn thích là
nghĩa được và Chính vì nó nhiều lý
thuyết quá nên mình cũng cũng rất ngại
dậy mới cài cho lý thuyết nhiều quá như
thế này kiểu gì Cần gì Các bạn cũng phải
tự học thôi
à à
Ừ nếu không đi học đại học thì tự học
thuật toán có khó khăn không
mình tự nghĩ việc này chứ mẹ tôi nghĩ
của việc họp tại học thì đào tạo về cơ
bản các thứ cái kiến thức nền có sợ là
tốt nhưng mà không có nghĩa là mà mình
đi học đại học thì sẽ gọi cho đấy đúng
không ạ Các bạn nghĩ cũng nghĩ hãy nghĩ
ngược lại một tí nó nhọn ra xử mình đi
học đại học Và thậm chí người ta dậy
trán thầy cô dạy khó hiểu thì mình còn
bị nản hơn bọn mình tự nhiên mình vẫn
đang nghĩa mình bị thiếu cái gì đó rồi
nên mình phải tình nhân là mình phải bổ
sung nó nóng lạnh để cho Suốt nó hơn đấy
đừng đừng nghĩ việc là bởi vì em đừng có
lấy Đấy lý do đúng ạ Trong cuộc sống anh
ấy thì đừng có lấy một cái gì trong quá
khứ biến thành lý do mình mình không
phấn đó không ạ Đừng bảo là do mày học
đại học em bây giờ thử toàn nên tao rốt
Ừ tao rốt tự nhận thế là quá say luôn
không ạ Dĩ nhiên là các bạn đưa họ trước
mình học sau để mình càng phải phấn đấu
nó giống như là mình từng hay nói sinh
viên mình đó là thứ nhất là các bạn ra
trường sớm hơn mày các bạn đi học đại
học chính quy cả bạn biết thực hành hơn
các bạn làm thực hành trước các bạn của
kinh nghiệm trước nhưng mà nền tảng đó
bạn vì ý thuyết trắng ạ Các bạn yếu hơn
thuật toán các bạn yếu hơn tư duy các
bạn có thể yếu hơn nữa Thế nên là khi mà
các bạn đi làm rồi tầm 25 nghiệm Mấy bạn
kia bắt được ra trường mấy bạn đấy có
thể làm tận hai ba năm
nhưng mà vẫn có thể đuổi kịp các bạn nếu
mà các bạn chỉ giậm chân tại chỗ ông
biết thực hành các bạn trong vòng 23 năm
đấy các bạn vẫn phải học thêm Nói chung
là những cái thứ mà còn thiếu mà hội mà
thời đi học mình có chứa làm rõ ông ạ Để
để mà bổ sung kiến thức mình - 23 năm
sau mà ông ấy ở bất kỳ được công chứng
tỏ ra ở mấy năm trước ông chỉ giậm trang
trại tại chỗ thôi
khi gặp lỗi cốt thì inbox trực tiếp được
không được bạn thoải mái thôi
nhưng mà đừng có cái gì cũng hỏi hơi quá
rồi chúng là các bạn được cân nhắc trước
khi ho những cái gì đó là cặp các bạn
phải trau chuốt việc là tìm tra Google
này sao ấy nói chung à
ờ ờ mặt tâm ở câu hỏi đừng có hỏi vu vơ
Anh ơi làm cái này thế nào chẳng hiểu
cái cái này là cái nào chẳng ạ
à à
thế hả vs code cài trợ lý ảo cái code
below copilot
copilot perf
này copilot của Vietjet này nó là kẻ ai
để mà kiểu trí tuệ nhân tạo để mà hỗ trợ
bạn lập trình Bạn sẽ tap dạy gõ tên Hàn
thôi ví dụ là kìa
đổi
đổi là tiền tệ lại hay đổi chuỗi thành
số nào ạ Nó sẽ gợi ý cho các bạn Các Hàn
đã từng có trên kết hấp rất là nhanh rất
tiện cho các bạn xem có để mô thì cái
cái này có ở trên cả đi sao à Có cả trên
pp tôm mà đấy gõ
cách kiểm tra số nguyên dương hay gì đó
gõ một tên hàng ra cả cốc cho mấy ông
kiểu Nga Trả Lại Anh
à à
Ừ nếu mà cái đấy p-sol có mà
kết quả máy họ nhiều phết đợi đi Tôi bị
trôi thử nhắn tin rồi
ừ ừ
anh hả
ơi các bạn ơi khi hỏi bảo mình nói giống
ai đó nhưng chúng ta mình mình xem ít
người khác lắm ở gần đây Công nhận cũng
đúng không thời gian để mà xem các thầy
tiếng Anh hay thay tại Việt Nam thì chắc
không biết mình chưa cha cũng không rõ
lắm
Ý mình nói bị giật ra ta có bạn nào cũng
bị thế không
Ừ đúng rồi theo mình biết để học đại học
thì tự học vẫn là chủ yếu hơn
đi công việc về di react thì có được đến
ra swift không
ra thì nó là nó chứ ở da spa nhỉ nó nó
là ribery Nha Real desktop ngay kiểu gì
các bạn sẽ biết về ra Speed trước khi
hợp với áo mà
ờ
ờ có nên cải thiện chữ cái kỹ năng làm
việc nhóm không Có chứ bởi vì a các bạn
về đấy Đấy do mình dạy các bạn làm đồ án
này bởi vì các bạn cái quen làm việc
người khác vì các bạn đi làm công ty các
bạn phải làm người khác chứ làm sao làm
một mình được đâu ạ
Ừ anh có phải đi nghĩa vụ quân sự không
coi hơi tế nhị gì đấy
thức da mịn nói về cái vụ này thứ mình
đã từng nghĩ về việc
đối đầu tiên thì rất là nó mình mình
thoải mái việc đi đấy
Cho dù là nó đúng à với dân công nghệ
mình tự nhiên 2 5 2 2 năm trở lại mà
mình không động máy tính chắc chắn mình
sẽ bị mai một kiến thức rồi các người
thứ đấy nhưng mà mình từng nghĩ là giờ
nó thí nghiệm thôi Ai cũng kiểu ai cũng
hiểu rằng mà
không không còn đi hai cổ này cái thứ
thì không con tốt rồi nó nghĩa vụ các
bạn sẽ phải phân biệt giữa quyền lợi
nghĩa vụ đấy phải luôn đi kèm với nhau
mình hồi đấy mình hơi truyền giáo dục
công dân nhé đấy thì
Ờ thế nên là mình tự bị
Anh ấn tượng xấu về hồi mà mình gặp anh
mutv lần lần này là lần thứ hai gặp anh
em UT mà ăn là người điên đâu sau đó đi
anh em nói việc là cách gì à đầu tiên
thì tự nhiên có người nhắc tới vụ đấy
thôi mấy anh em cái gì rồi chỉ nhau kiểu
không phải mẹo những nó chỗ Mà kiểu cũng
nói kiểu này nè nhé Tìm cách để né việc
không Không đi thì ta thì đầy ấn tượng
xấu mình bởi vì à cứ như là mấy anh đấy
có dân công nghệ và cũng kiểu cũng chung
là nguồn thu nhập chính có một các thứ
vân vân Nhưng mà mình kiểu cảm thấy nghĩ
ra kìa
từ hôm nay như thế nếu mà anh cũng nghĩ
quyền lợi riêng của mình ga thì sẽ sai
vẫn phải có từ nghĩa vụ đấy ông ạ Các
bạn dịch được cái từ nhiệm vụ mà các bạn
thấy bọn nó thí nghiệm mình
nhà mình có nghĩa vụ và quyền lợi công
dân không ạ Các bạn đòi họ quyền lợi như
các bạn không làm gì để mà kiểu anh nói
chung nào Trách nhiệm của các quyền lợi
đấy đạt được vỡ nợ đấy các bạn mình như
không có quân đội
Em có cách nào để xác định mấy đứa trẻ
trâu
đối với mình trẻ trâu là nửa không quan
tâm người khác nghĩ gì về mình theo cậu
lại làm ảnh hưởng người khác như không
quan tâm người khác nghĩ gì về mình sẽ
Châu
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà nhắc cái vụ nghĩa vụ quân
sự đấy mình không phải mình ăn mình cũng
cận nhưng mà mình không ạ Vì cận Mình
không đi được mà mình bị ạ Cũng bị bệnh
về
Nói chung về sức khỏe nên là mình Khám
khám người ta miễn
Và cho đến hiện tại thế Mình bị bệnh rồi
sức khỏe cái A mấy ông cũng nên giữ sức
một tí
Ừ kệ ai xin xin thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn
anh không biết mình sẽ dậy các bạn không
Nhưng tại Khánh xin nó chị đơn giản là
cái đợi đội cái thằng kia kích chạy xong
thôi mà
thì các bạn nộp đấy mình mình chuẩn bị
chậm đây ạ
A8 nay thì mình không đánh giá ngon hơn
Bởi Vì à Vì nó Chị ở gợi ý một ít hơn mà
nó đọc cốt mình nhưng mà nghe nói và sẽ
sẵn nguồn ra tắt này ngủ ngoan hơn và nó
mất phí mà
em bỏ ra mày trăm triệu ra học đại học 4
năm trong đi nghĩa vụ
gì hả ông là bây giờ chẳng bỏ tiền ra để
học cái gì đó Đang gì gì đó đang kiếm
rất nhiều hay gì đó Đang tuổi trẻ tự
nhân vật đi nhưng mà
Ừ thì thi đấy ai ai cũng như thế thôi
mình mình nghĩ mình một phần nhưng mà
mình nghĩ việc cả ai cũng như thế nó sự
bình đẳng ấy mình mình có không coi mình
là rõ hơn là cái gì cả ngoại
Ừ cái này cũng như điểm thôi không nói
về dân mình nói ngược điện nó kéo chúng
ta hiểu hay nghĩ lợi ích bản thân nhưng
trước này cũng bây giờ nghĩ việc à Ở tìm
cách khôn lỏi hả lách luật có thứ cho
bản thân cá nhân mình tôi tôi không ủng
hộ mình cái vấn đề đấy
3 cách tính độ phức tạp ngay từ hơi bị
nhiều nhỉ Cho lại bạn
mình mình chỉ khuyên Nếu bạn muốn tìm
hiểu về queo hình nên biết về
explain để mà cậu nó sẽ giải thích câu
ép kia các bạn như thế nào từ ống cuối
trong đó việc là độ phức tạp của câu
lệnh nặng có trong đấy
thế hả Không không tôi bị gầy như tôi
không bị còi xương mới gọi đâu Thôi ngăm
ngăm cân mà có cái này đâu nhỉ À đúng là
gầy thật nhưng mà có đến nỗi kiểu thiếu
dinh dưỡng đến nỗi không đi được nghĩa
vụ đó không hoài vì thế
nộp bài kiểu gì À thì các bạn đăng lên
kết hát để mà mình phải tải về thôi
bài hát bạn kia Bà nói lại về ở sát ở
quê à nói chuyện Đợi khá đội thằng này
chạy Xong rồi mà tôi tôi hình dung nó
mới đợi thằng này đợi thằng này gọi đến
kiểu gọi đến ai kia xong trả về dữ liệu
thì mình lấy được dữ liệu đấy Còn nếu
không mọi khi thì thay gọi theo này chạy
Xong rồi thằng ở dưới mà gọi em biến
hàng ngày chưa chắc gọi được ngồi kìa
bởi vì thằng ra quyết xử lý bất đồng bộ
mà nó nhà thằng nhàng chạy và thằng này
lập tức có thể chạy xuống dưới luôn Nếu
mà không có web này thì thôi
ở đâu kia nói với nút tiền nói không nói
mấy cái
tai nạn với cái xấu đấy trên đây nhé bởi
vì à
Ừ nó bảo rồi à
ở Tuyên cái
chỉ có vài cái thì tôi không ủng hộ mấy
ông tôi không có
tôi không coi mình là một con người
gương mẫu thì đánh giá ai cả nhưng mà
chưa ra tối không ủng hộ những cái kiểu
chết và nó không tốt ai mà em làm thế
thì thì
ở xã hội và đất nước này sẽ đi về đâu
anh như thế
ừ ừ
à à
khi sex
anh đi xong bạn đi xong về bạn bè người
ta 2 năm kinh nghiệm thực ra đi nói vụ
đi vụ thì nó sẽ không phải là các bạn
tốn thời gian không tràn đầy làm gì cho
bạn sẽ học hỏi thêm những gì khác hoặc
nghe nói vẫn tôi vẫn nghe nó thường
xuyên ở việc à đi xong thì các bạn sẽ có
chụp ảnh hơn rồi có thứ con người có kỷ
luật hơn là chung à Nhiều người còn lúc
đầu trước khi đi thì ghét nó nén xong
rồi đi xong thì quen rồi những kiểu sẽ
thấy gợi nhớ anh khỏe thế
anh
nói chung à cái việc đấy thì tôi tôi
không hẳn là tôi nói tôi mong muốn chảy
nghiện nhưng mà ở
Ừ cái này thì các bạn Nếu giống như tôi
từng nói rồi nếu mà các bạn hãy suy nghĩ
thêm một góc nhìn khác không nghĩ theo
cậu dạng là
góc nhìn hiện tại nữa mà thử nghĩ theo
góc nhìn khác làm chỉ nó là một điều
hiển nhiên em ạ sống ở bên Hàn Quốc tế
tôi có xe máy vượt kỳ hạn đi với cả thần
tượng cực kỳ ai Nguyễn Thụ đi bây giờ
thế Coi mỗi nó một điều hiển nhiên ấy
thì các bạn sẽ thấy rất bình thường
khi thần tượng các bạn ca sĩ các thứ thứ
thời gian kiếm tiền như thế Cái ta đang
tuổi trẻ tình cảm vân vân cũng đi nhưng
họ đi với tinh thần nó thoải mái họ còn
thiếu quay hẳn kiểu Họ biến nó biến đấy
anh kiểu dạng là lúc mày đi
vừa đi truyền hình thực tế vẫn có truyền
hình rất là thứ
anh không biết Mà họ sướng hay khổ nhé
mẹ mà tao nói họ cho là nghĩ khác rồi
ừ ừ
khi sex
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi nghe nó có được tiền em ạ
em hết câu hỏi rồi đem mình sẽ xanh đấy
Nhìn thấy cốt mà em theo không kịp cái
cái này bạn hãy nói buổi hôm trước hôm
trước mình cốt giun để có buổi video khá
đời ít người xem không biết được là do
Không muốn xem thì khó quá Hay là mấy
ông sẽ phát hiểu luôn nhưng heo ở nếu
không xem lại tôi không biết được nhưng
mà thực ra thì tội biết được mình cái
điều đấy Kiểu gì nó sẽ đến tất cả nhưng
mà tôi vẫn sẽ dạy Bởi vì thực ra ở gần
nhưng bây giờ như tự nói là hết cái cơ
bản để mà các bạn thì học rồi lần như
thế là là buổi tôi ghi nâng cao được
ở đâu mà mày cứ ở đấy tôi cho mọi người
biết qua về thư viện Green nói thế chứ
như thế nào với vân vân là con chưa Đúng
rồi hôm hôm mà và
thông báo lịch nghỉ Tết sớm nha cho tôi
sẽ đăng bài thông báo sau Tết là hôm nào
nghỉ à
chợ
tết Âm
Ừ mùng 1 luôn à
Thì như thế Chắc ngày 29 thôi nghỉ ngày
29 nhớ là đúng hai tuần nữa mình sẽ nghỉ
Tết nghỉ thì đi đấy nhé ơi méo nhỉ chị
nha nếu thế ngày thứ 3 thứ 5 này thứ 3
thứ 5 này chúng ta con bốn buổi nữa này
một Dạy hết về ghi thưa nghe thấy lại
thành rất ngắn nó thì nên bốn người nữa
sẽ dạy hết sức
có thể toàn bộ những cái đống ở đây này
nữ cán bộ những từ đống này trong
444 buổi nữa đây thì có những buổi kia
chấm mà nó Ngoãn là qua có thể thứ
ạ sau đó thì sau đó thì nghỉ tết à nghỉ
Tết mùng một nóng lại nghỉ đến tận à
Cứ cho là mùng 10 đi
ông cho ông đúng mùng 10 đến cứ đi học
rồi thì dùng 10 thì mình sẽ
tính sẽ cẩu trở dậy nốt cái gì được thì
dậy Đúng
rồi
12 chấm này à Xong rồi bị hẳn một tuần
sau chị bảo vệ thử đi cũng được sao rồi
đến ngày 22 đã bảo vệ thật
U22 26 nghỉ Tết nhé nghỉ nói chung rồi
xong cái tuần này bảo vệ sử Tôi nghĩ à
bảo vệ thử hai buổi xong rồi ngày 19 bảo
vệ thật cũng được 19 26 bảo vệ thuật bảo
vệ thật hay buổi đi một buổi cũng không
hết được đâu ừ thôi nghĩa thấy khá hợp
lý nhé mình sẽ mình trong tháng 2 là có
ngờ mình sẽ bảo vệ xong được cái đầu á
đông ạ Con các bạn bảo vệ đợt 2 thì mình
sẽ sắp xếp sau nha thực hiện đợt 1 trước
mắt là như thế đã
A
ha vậy ông kia hỏi về localstorage biết
này Vision biết này api Ok với đồng bộ
mấy cái đấy cha tôi nói nói được
trò chơi Chọn từ khóa làm yêu
ha ha
em có dậy về matchy-matchy nước à máy
móc hay ở dưới Man Chị ở đây mà chị Linh
về đây ai mua chili người cho chị nhé
3 cách để fix lỗi khi không dùng được
chị luôn chịu chịu
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
Ừ ok sao
vi phạm tâm sự tương đỗ rồi bây giờ mình
thử trầm qua từng nhóm
ở nhóm nhé
thì mình ảnh xem lại kể hôm trước tôi bị
lười chấm rồi Mấy bữa bà Thực ra cũng
hơi buồn đấy Cứ mỗi lần chắn khi lại
buồn một việc
ta có ba nhóm để cứ mỡ là lúc tôi chấm
giao nhì và nhóm bỏ mấy ông ạ tớ buồn mà
anh dường nhà chịu
à à
ừ ừ
anh ngắm một thùng trước được rồi những
cái Ngó mà hôm trước tôi bánh xe có nhớ
hôm nay tặng nhà cho rằng nhé
ở đây một loạt nhóm mới nhưng mà rất
nhiều bạn trên đây lại đó tôi Cho Anh do
có tí nói chung ngày mai ngày mai đi
không ai Tôi thì mệt kinh không Thi Mai
thi liên thông rất là dễ nói thẳng là
được mở bảo vào
nhưng mà
nhưng mà vẫn đứng như vẫn tốn thời gian
có thể thử không ạ mất sự cá cuối tuần
nó hư hư hư
anh
buồn lắm mày ông không biết được ở tối
thiểu bị thiếu thốn hơi gian như thế nào
đây bởi vì làm ở công ty thì ạ nhiều lúc
cũng căng mà nó tôi tính Tôi máu nữa tôi
một ngày đó xong là thằng một tính năng
nhưng mà cái vì cái máu nên thành ra
nhiều hôm được thấy ngồi sửa lại thì hôm
trước ngồi cốt nhanh quá không tính hết
các trường hợp ý
Đại học An ninh học tin thông từng nói
rồi đấy đấy tôi thêm câu nữa Chắc hai
tội về sao dễ hãy cho nó chặn bóp mình
học lên hông có để lấy cái bằng à
bằng cử nhân vì mình học nghề nên buổi
trưa không có bằng đại học chính quy Tìm
kiếm bằng đại học chính quy để mà còn là
giờ sau đi dạy được vợ chưa À quên không
cần bán và giao diện nhé tôi vào thẳng
luôn cốt xem nhé ạ
a passport nhân viên đã có quản lý 12
khác nhau à
à à
cô đơn hàng tra kiểm tra Kirby sản phẩm
trước đi Mày không Mày không ổn phải ra
đấy nhá và hết bên bên này đầu tiên để
ông ai có thể OnePlus kiểm tra xóa OK
là nó xác nhận ra thêm thêm form này
nhóm 1 vẫn ấy bảo chưa về đến nhà nó
ở nhà mua chưa phải đến cho thiếu đi
ngắm hay sao mà à
Cho xem hài Kiều tranh
hi vọng tên là con gái
ừ ừ
Ừ
em nói đi
customer Index Cũng được Cũng đúng không
Không nên tạo khách hàng mới thấy hàng
tự đăng ký
các bạn này cũng thế mà không cho xóa
sửa xóa cũng được
ở bên sản phẩm đi
ô tô sat-address Hà Đông Triều Tiên ạ
Glass đã
tôi thích bạn là tên Glass này update
này về sau Lazio nó sẽ kiểu theo cơ chế
ngay nhận như thế Không còn đi led đâu
nếu mà theo Maria thì thoại nó là tên nó
đi choy cơ mà chưa về sau tôi nhớ chỉ
thêm vào level trừ sâu hơn mấy ông sẽ
dùng trong vụ này
anh không có ai biết rồi không có vẻ
không pha biết bằng ra sức với thử xem à
Để mai xem
chưa ra đếch gì rồi thì đi linh tinh là
em vẫn vào được
ừ ừ
à à
ở bến khách hàng đi sẽ bị khách hàng B
khách hàng có Viber rồi lại
ô kê
anh nha mới chỉ vài đêm vắng khách hàng
thôi thiếu không ạ Vẫn thiếu
anh cứ để tạm mày ạ để làm nên bật lên
để ít à Ok vậy cảm nữa đây là lừa
ờ ờ
ở vòng 3
ừ ừ
à à
khi
Apple Docs
Khi
nào mày cũng vẻ chưa về hết à Có vé đắt
bác em
Anh
chưa về đêm ở quán em cũng cũng tạm được
đã các bạn vào đây trước mà các bạn nên
ưu tiên ra bếp bằng Bayern trước mấy
kiểu gì nó đấy chắc chắn phải cần không
ạ Nó chưa có thời gian thì các bạn làm
thêm Varus do mình không không
mình không chấm cắt các bạn với vụ hoa
Tết nhớ rất là nó là nó dễ một điểm cộng
thêm nếu mà các bạn ạ hả
xu hướng dẫn cách link cs-gas khi dùng
grub
bộ phim sex với Ý bạn lắm
ờ ờ
các bạn nên ra đấy thì nó sẽ được cộng
điểm vào tránh lỗi vì sáu sẽ phát sinh
đâu mà đúng không ạ
À mà hôm bảo vệ đoán Cho tôi hỏi mấy ông
ngoài các tính năng kiểu gì lỗi hỏi mấy
ông nhiều vụ da chết và lôgích ấy
nói chung là không phải cái gì được xem
thêm sửa xóa và không phải cái gì được
cái xóa gì bây giờ vẫn kiểm tra hết kĩ
vụ đấy phét ý
Ừ
ok nhóm 3 phải được rồi này à
ở nhóm 5
à à
ừ ừ
các bạn nam của đất ở khi
quét
Mở ông ấy chơi Mình nhớ không được mong
này cho ok vậy
ở đài nào
I was From A
ý lắng ai sự kiện để hiển thị ra thôi
Kiều ba đến rồi
Ừ cái này bà đấy bằng bác em này cũng
được hết cả bến phân anh nữa thì ổn hơn
ra bìa là các bạn này góp gộp chung hai
iPhone vào là một rồi các bạn chỉ cần vé
đúng Mobifone Thôi được
à à Bạn kia bảo dùng pp để in prussia
không dùng HTML thuần thôi chứ tại sao
mất không thấy
356 à
à à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ ông ấy làm cái gì ngoài chưa cây
thương một lại rất riêng Delete riêng ạ
Không không ai chưa thức mục 12A
3000 ai chưa thêm một ngày đâu rồi ông
ấy là tên Glass là cứ hết nữa Tôi chẳng
biết này Cái gì cơ ạ
cho
thuê nhân viên à
anh ở bên tay kiểu này không hiểu đâu
à Chưa trường hợp vợ ok chưa trường hợp
để mà thêm
anh cũng hơi lạ
cái này phù hợp cho mời xe ok mvc Vì sao
các bạn làm thì các bạn sẽ đúng nó chơi
trường hợp tưởng nha bây giờ hướng như
trong hơi lạ thật thường là người đã
không áp dụng như cái kiểu như này
ăn trộm sao nhưng mà làm thế này đấy làm
như này ông còn khó phai biết hơn thì
ông chen file cũng đăng nha à ừ ừ
anh
cũng vào bếp qua với gạch rồi cho lọc nó
hư thứ cũng tương đối ok
156 157
thế
hả chấm gà bên A
chú ý bạn ở chuẩn Bên khách hàng nữa
đúng không Không thực ra tôi đang chấm
ngẫu nhiên đấy mấy ông Tý sẽ biết rồi
chồng ngẫu nhiên em ạ Con chấm vừa rồi
đấy giống nhiêu rồi chấm nhẹ admin xong
rồi bé nhìn không được chấm cho mấy Hà
mà tĩnh ngược lại tí theo chuẩn mới
khách hàng trước ông nào mà thiếu gì tôi
ở quay sang bên emminh ngoạn
Ừ ông ông không đoán được tôi đâu để ông
Đoàn tôi để mà
như thế tôi hết thứ mà chấm ăn ngon mấy
ông sẽ trình nhè và đúng vitamin để làm
à Không ai chơi thế
anh
chia sẻ cách quản lý hoặc chia thư mục
thế nào
đoán một thìa các bạn rất khó làm chuyên
nghiệp nhiều cái vì các bạn cốt đang
Thuần không theo mô hình gì cả thành ra
là bây giờ mình chỉnh dạy các bạn nút
tương đối là à Ừ thì bảng nào thì tách
nó nói chung vào cái mục nào tách riêng
mà ra thành một cây thư mục thôi còn đến
đồ án 2 thì mình dậy các bạn phía sau
hơn này việc à
file nên như thế nào tên pha như thế nào
tên biến như thế nào nó hẳn quy chuẩn
lượn luôn ấy chuẩn quy chuẩn của bên nào
đấy nào trả lại thấy sau đó tên bảng như
thế nào ngồi thư mục nên như là cái gì
nên để ở pha nào đấy phải nói rõ tất cả
những cái điều đấy đối ngoại và đết nên
ở phải nào phải phải riêng này cái tư
thử kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu nên ở file nào
đấy Tất cả những cái đấy phải theo quy
tắc
ở đây điểm mà về sau các bạn muốn sửa
cái gì Các bạn vào đúng mỗi chỗ đấy là
sửa tất cả chậu khác vẫn phải chạy vẫn
bình thường đấy là theo mô hình chuột và
dễ bảo chị dẫn nâng cấp đáng theo đồng ý
bạn đó ông ạ
có người đón một thì các bạn còn đang
còn chưa hình dung được các bạn đã có
cái gì Nói thẳng như thế thì làm sao mà
biết được là phải sửa cái gì Vân biết
lãm ảnh tối ưu không các bạn chưa biết
gì cả nên là mình không đọc hỏi liệu
khác em mình không yêu cầu gì đó được
không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Mình đang làm chung với anh
em kêu tít mày Ông đừng đến lấy đốt nhá
bây giờ hiện lại không ai trả lời đó
đốt thì
ông đốt chẳng nói lý do gì cả
Ai cũng ra hết rồi này được phép này à
à à
37 và đội cận hạn phết
cho tôi thường Ai bảo nhóm này nữ làm
nhưng thật ra đã thế là ông con trai làm
đấy nhớ giao diện mà nó không biết làm à
nữ ở Nam nữa
nó chín thiệu có cái nhóm chính thiếu bỏ
qua luôn ngắm 11 thiếu màu qua 13
Hôm nay tôi sẽ biến khách hàng trước à
à Không để trồng cây dâm bụt thôi cũng
được không trả lời được cái Hà mà
cô Đắc này à
v-app tocard ok à
anh
không biết vậy thì bạn đấy này nếu biết
là thiếu violet đoạn nào cái sản phẩm
này không được dạy rằng người dùng nhập
ID sang phải không còn lại giả
này thiếu đúng không ạ
anh không kiểm tra 3D ở bên nhà Sign Vậy
nha sẽ đi nữa à
sự
thiếu hòa để ra clip đúng không ạ
các
bạn Ai mới chỉ làm tất hạn mức cơ
A gọi là làm chạy được rồi chưa vai đấy
gì cả Có uae con này được nghỉ
khô kèm cái thứ thử nhưng mà thiếu ra để
rồi bổ sung 3d đến khách hàng đúng không
Đó bây giờ rồi anh ở sang bên amin này
thấy không
Ê mấy ông cụ đoán tôi
áo bóng đá Đức Gấu uống
thì lộ hết bài chứ
chứ không phải vào đây đi rồi
ok ngoài chiều á
không thiếu nhưng mà chị không đi lỗi có
rồi
được tạm châm chước cho qua
anh hả
à à
tủ sách của thầy hiệu trưởng nhóm và
thấy á
Ừ tôi sẽ không nói gì về vấn đề đấy à
à à
cả
hai phần mềm Again Nhìn chất phát ra
trong kỹ thuật black mask lúc này ao nhớ
tai nạn mục riêng để mà Hiển thị các
hướng đăng nhập Vì sao
suýt để anh trên check Ồ bạn check lại
access access này biết danh chả rồi thưa
chữa rồi
mở cửa chữ s hả
Có ai thấy cái của tôi gợi ý do sai xanh
dạ thế gợi ý không nó nhiều axit
để access access là những ai thôi à
có nét có thì như không kiểm tra gợi ý
chính là đâu
cho tôi biết bởi vì anh nhiều nhiều cũng
bên bên công ty tôi có vài ông làm vé
cốt mà và có nhiều lỗi chính tả phản bội
Ông ấy không bao được gợi ý sửa nên tôi
biết mà cái của tôi gợi ý Kiểm tra lỗi
chính tả kiểm tra diễn biến nó trong
nhiều cá lắm gợi ý nói chung là IDM mà
nó gợi ý các thứ thứ về sau tôi dậy các
bạn bên nào với các bạn sẽ rõ hơn là
việc nó gợi ý ngon như thế nào tiện phết
phụ trách thực ra không phải là tên là
chết đuối getlist tơ mà check virus
Blaster thì nó còn hơn và Virus Blaster
cũng được
sự phân rã Phân rõ Tôi Thích bản này xin
rõ ra thương như vậy ổi dùng led cứ kê
với khách hàng lỗi gì nữa
à à
Ê cu đất cứ mỗi mãi vô đắt mãi chán nhỉ
Ừ tôi không biết được bên này mấy ông
này có virus không thường mà không sẽ ưu
tiên bên phố đắt nhất
ô ồ pallet đổ cả nho này ngon ngon
em coi kiểm tra chặt chẽ hết kiểm tra
rừng không được phép sửa cả amin có sử
dụng được ngắm rất lâu
à à
Ừ đấy thì mấy ông hoàn toàn là nhìn vào
thì mấy ông đừng có tôi bảo được cái mục
đích của cái việc chấm này mày Không
không phải cô ấy em cái giỏi quá Thôi
nào mình loại cái thử không thì nhớ
chẳng ai bị loại trừ phi ông chả làm cái
gì cả chứ thứ hai là người ông phải biết
được là tôi về cơ bản hồi đồ ăn 1 của
tôi sẽ sẵn không được như thế này đúng ạ
Thế nên là mấy ông rất là rõ hơn tôi rồi
nhé là tôi không ngờ tự tin vì tự ti vì
lấy chồng ngoại mình học hỏi thôi mà
mình thấy à họ có yêu và nhập nha không
ạ Nếu mà ngược thì mình né là còn yêu
thì mình không bảo chẳng sao mà
anh tới mục đích của cái buổi này không
phải là buổi để quên mẽ ông nào cốt hay
hơn ông nào đúng ạ Ông nào Chỗ kém hơn
ông nào ấy không
nghe đấy Mi ông hay có góc nhìn khác
mình không sẽ cuộc sống của ông sẽ khác
Thăm mấy ông có góc nhìn tiêu cực thì
cuộc sống của ông sẽ đúng được biến hình
cực đúng ạ hả từ khi Tại sao vừa nãy tâm
sự thì lên 100 người bắt đầu ngồi chấm
bài mấy ông xuống 70 Vậy
hả 9 giờ đến giờ chúc bé ngủ ngon à à
đi câu Anh có chơi coi không dễ thêm một
câu nữa vào trong mà danh sách những câu
Ừ tôi sẽ cho con Chắc bóp
trả lời tự động không có coi cùng đấy
Không coi không chứng khoán không cổ
phiếu không ạ mà mở ô
Ừ tôi không không Tôi bị không ham mặt
chất thành ra là nếu hỏi thôi mày có đấy
Tôi không chắc chắn là tôi sẽ trả lời là
không có phí bác này thôi bỏ qua đi Bỏ
qua ở
ở phố Doctor ghi
rõ ràng à
à à
ừ ừ
anh
em đổ cố lắm Hẹn đường phố rất lạ ơi
để
thêm sản phẩm I
số tự nhiên có hai thay dầu ở đây này có
cốt rồi không có loạn rồi
thế mới sản phẩm mà tao đúng không ạ
Ừ để sửa máu
đây là sửa
tiêu đề ở trên này một cái sản phẩm cái
thêm sản phẩm có nhầm rồi đấy Lạ update
thì ổn hơn không
anh thiếu thiếu và Lebanon đấy ạ
khi cài vào đến một tí nha và đến này
chị Ba đến 1 file thôi thiếu
I am in
public là gì
Ừ
ông ấy mẹ ông đã chơi chồng mới xe hết
này à
I love in a
anh
cũng GV các thứ thứ rồi nhưng mà không
chơi à Tao cũng được lại đi đấy ạ
a permanent
Nhìn bề ngoài là phức tạp nhỉ
ờ ờ restore
khi thiếu bài đễ rồi nhóm mày làm khá
nhiều như kiểu qua đến mất rồi 17
anh
không Mình hiện tại không thời gian để
xem chữ m nào ngoài à xem
bình luận là cô ta rồi ngày nào rồi Xem
đôi ta vui mà à
anh
nói thế xong bây giờ còn sống với ông ạ
Ok thế là tôi không quan tâm tới bảo rồi
chị Bây giờ có mỗi 34 ông thì vẫn dạy
thời hồi trước tôi
mở câu lạc bộ cũng thấy mà tự nhiên là
thế thì tội mình sẽ phải xem lại việc
tại sao mà lượng người xem ra như thế
mình đã làm gì đó gì sai thì mình phát
ngôn gì đó quá không ạ nhưng mà ý tôi là
kiểu Bởi vì thứ nhất là tôi không dậy
mất tiền thằng ai kia không thu phí thì
các bạn việc với bạn dạy các bạn vào xem
nhiều hai xe buýt thì cho tôi không quan
tâm không muốn mình thành con người rất
nổi tiếng
một con người cũng nhiều người biết Mến
là nhiều người cứ dặn thì ra ổn không
muốn nổi tiếng nổi tiếng mệt lắm rất
nhiều thứ vấn đề cân nhắc trong lời nói
nó cứ do ngồi nhiều có người sẽ ghét
mình Về Đất Mẹ
á nhon Em thử nghĩ mày Mẹ nội trợ
anh có kiểm tra qua này Đấy kiểm tra qua
thôi không là không thể xóa các từ từ
chứ không phải 3D hoàn toàn
ờ ờ ờ
à à
em
kiểm tra không được để trống cũng tương
đối t
à à
ừ ừ
He
has a
à à
khi
xem phim
Tôi đang không hiểu ông này nữa để bên ạ
a đây Đấy từ trong ai không ạ ok ok à
Ừ ông ấy cũng rủ ai đi à
Ừ anh ông giống nhau à
gì sai đâu à
anh có kiểm tra này
anh sex ta sẽ viết đúng chính tả này
Ừ ok ok
thiếu bên emminh nữa kiểu Việt Nam II đã
ở nhóm 18
năm 18
cô dâu ta nghe như nhậu nha
anh không Dota 2 mà không ra người ta
phân tích con hư Hử tôi thấy nó đỡ buồn
ngủ Liên Minh Liên Minh ờ xem cứ ngồi
Phan ngủ dậy chưa chiến thuật thì thực
ra thì chưa Này vốn vẫn thế không có sự
cố gì đây rồi chọn tướng cái khác chế
hoàn toàn rồi Không còn sự lật kèo gì
lắm không độ xóa
à à
ở mấy cái này sau được công khai để tham
khảo không ờ ờ
Ừ cái này thì à
Ừ chắc để chính các nhóm đấy đi chính
cái nhóm đấy vì sau còn muốn đăng tăng
lên không mình thì mình tôn trọng số cốt
các bạn cho rồi cho chị do chính mình
dậy nữa mình sẽ tôn trọng các bạn thứ
nhất là sẽ xóa đi dọn sẽ đi thì tôi nữa
loài chim ngồi xóa mày không xem không
chữa lỗi ổ cứng khô khôi phục lại được
thứ hai là
tự gỡ tôi khỏi mấy cái Zippo lại Nếu vài
ông lang để chế độ mình cậu riêng tư với
đấy
cũng phải nhắc tôi tôi hãy quên nhưng
nói chung là tôi không dùng của mấy ông
và tôn trọng họ mì dân công nghệ mình sẽ
tôn trọng chứ xám lẫn nhau đấy thì
thế nên nhóm nào mà muốn có thể chia sẻ
cho mọi cho các bạn khác để tham khảo
thì tùy thôi mình mình không ủng hộ và
mình cũng chẳng kiến gì cả à
à
Còn việc là tự ý mình dùng số code của
mấy ông làm gì chắc là nó không Rồi nhất
là tôi không cần để lấy thứ hai à không
để đạo đức lệnh nghiệp đạo đức nghề
nghiệp ở đây vừa đã được làm thay vừa
đạo đức vừa
làm dân đồng nghiệp với nhau
ừ ừ
à à
mục
tiêu đề đây là giao diện amin thế Ôm tất
cả mọi file đều được cũng là một ý hay
có về đây này nếu tách nó ra file riêng
nhé
Ok
good luck bố sẽ được tắt hẳn ra đây à
hơi Dị à Dị
đi lên đi nào ạ
ô ồ kiểm tra nhé Kiểm tra thế này chị ạ
cũng cũng được
đã được khách ấy xong gọi chị dịp khác
tôi không biết gọi được mày nữa Hay nhỉ
à thì các bạn đúng dậy các bạn mở mang
thêm một vài cái
mới nhưng mà mấy cái này thì ra với dạo
không áp dụng được lợi nhuận đã áp dụng
trả thù gian dụng được lại những thứ
cách code các hướng sử xác ah cho tôi
thì tôi vẫn dị ứng dùng hàm đai mình
dùng hả mày ship Tôi ở hai thằng như
nhau nhưng mà die thì đối với tôi con
điểm bay nó để đi bốc mày ra lỗi gì đó
còn anh chí là để nhát tại đấy theo đúng
như tên của nó
thực hai hàng đúng là mục đích là như
nhau
anh
em mình đang chuẩn đây 18 nữa à
U19
U19 thiếu U21
ghét u xơ info Tại có hình tượng thông
tin có sự tự do
cái gì
thế thôi à Ok chắc là fan chen ở chỗ
khác vô Sếp à
Ừ
cái này là cái eo rồi Sợ không sao nhưng
mà hết đồ trong nên có axit thì nó kết
thúc luôn hạn chế tránh việc như này
xuống dưới nhau Nó cho anh không Đã
kiểu này cũng được đóng đóng này
mà thiếu nha hiểu
à Hiểu ba đến mất rồi
chị
xem bên anh đi đâu à à
khi các bạn làm nhiều file phết nhiều
file hơn hồi trước cứ ngồi chê Đồ ăn
mình nhiều file Các bạn nhìn lại các bạn
nhiều phải kinh khủng không hiểu các bạn
đã làm những gì trong đúng này rồi chúng
Sợ thế
đồ ăn hay rất là nhiều file hơn nhưng mà
nhớ file file rồi Ít giảm hơn vài ngập
ngập trắng cũng bắt đầu dọn rất là dài
tay giặt rồi à
Cả
Ngố tôi bắt đầu đang tự hỏi mấy ông Tại
sao Nếu phải làm đúng ngay
bởi một cái ông lạ mặt ở trên mạng Ông
ấy bảo mày ông làm em để không làm đúng
không
I ia overview cái gì đấy
em xin nghỉ thống kê à chị nhưng mà đặt
tên thư mục mẹ bố sách hơi khó hiểu
để thêm sản phẩm bay rồi
à không để xem là Phạm gì cả
- Paul ak00 cho thêm à
Ừ Tôi muốn hỏi hai mông lung hả em yêu
ai tầm là thêm sản phẩm à
ở nhóm này đặt tên file cả thư mục hơi
gì kể
đề kiểm tra
Em thử thử nhưng mà không kiểm tra không
pha đếch được lắm
ừ ừ
anh ở đây có về về phòng đấy
được à
à à
Ê mấy ông phải thống nhất về cách đặt
tên biến là tên file và thư mục nhé
Không phải hướng lên nữa này không lên
kia thì cốt của mấy ông vừa rồi cốt của
mấy ông còn dài nữa Mấy người kia đọc bỏ
qua thằng kiểu gì à Bỏ qua anh nhá chết
rồi
Ừ ông ấy không yêu thương mùa quả Ừ tôi
không biết rồi nhắc ngoài giờ thì anh
nhắc rồi ông ấy chẳng thu mua việc chồng
hết rồi trong thùng ăn minh sẽ được nó
hợp lý
đồng
hồ kiểm tra tên ở Đức Trọng Thôi các thứ
xịn xịn
a Vietnamese
Ừ để moselle call
call đệm kê
[âm nhạc]
khi nhún rỡ để mu ra là gì đấy
ở
phiên bản tiếng mèo
I say in size được Sign
Em có phải rồi
lễ
hội mẹ ruột
U23
còn 3 nhóm nữa cho nốt loại nhóm mình
nghỉ nhé ngày 3
em chạy ra đi
kiểm tra phải điền đầy đủ thông tin
tương đối thêm hàng ngày và bếp cũng
được
à à
Ẩm Thực ra thế này vẫn còn chưa đủ các
bạn phải kiểm tra việc là email cùng sẽ
chung nữa các bạn không được Tạo Hai
người cùng chung email không ạ
ở ngã ba đến là phải cẩn thận như thế
Ngoài việc và kiểm tra nhập nhập đúng
này đủ này phải phải là không bị ngập
Thừa Đã không có bị gì không bị xóa thừa
không được cập nhật những cái trong tình
trạng như thế nào Nóng mạ vân vân vân để
mẹ và hết ngọn Thế nên cái từ verdad nó
rất là rộng những dịch ra ông ạ
tiếng Anh thì gói gọn trong mẹ ngắn gọn
thế thôi nếu là đến nó rất là rất là
phức tạp nên là thế nên mới bảo là các
bạn phải làm xong hết đã thì có phải
virus là một và Violet thì phải bắt rất
nhiều trường hợp các bạn nào mà càng làm
vậy và đến tốt thì tư duy các bạn càng
tốt kiểu các bạn càng kỹ tính để mà
người về sau làm công việc có thứ mà
thân mình làm ở công ty Thế mình à Thế
mình không hẳn con người cần hợp lắm
nhưng mình cũng biết mấy cái đấy rồi đấy
Mình biết rồi mình chỉ nhận đúng rồi anh
em mình cũng mua khi mình kỹ mình có
người trường hợp
nhưng như đã nói mình không hẳn kỹ tin
nhắn mình Mình biết làm đấy nhưng mà
không phải quên đâu nhưng mà tưởng nhiều
lúc cũng chìa khóa có
chợ hoa những cái bên kiểu biến amin thì
được ơi Không hẳn cẩn cho cái thực tế ở
bên An Ninh thì đúng ạ Không cần phải
vào đây cầu toàn quá gì À bởi vì onme mà
thành người ta biết người ta đã lại phải
làm gì nên này ra dễ hơn dễ thở lý có
nên khách hàng nói đúng rồi Rất là chặt
chẽ với khách hàng nó sẽ phá mình hết
pin thì không chịu phá ăn mì phán thì tự
họ chịu rồi nó nó
a
Lemon đang ở đâu vậy
tại sao cứ sợ mở có thư mục admin Delete
này ông định đi lấy tiền ở đây
ông ấy đang bài
xe ngựa ngoài cho đăng bài có đi lấy tin
tức này
ừ ừ
I say in rồi bay rồi
anh không thấy ở ở ngoài cho người dùng
đăng nhập gửi
xe
hơi lạ
khi bệnh khách hàng triệu bà hết
I am in và Rồi mình kiểm tra chưa nhỉ
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi ngày vẫn tương đối
Bên nhóm 23 thiếu
à à
329 à
1529 có mỗi khác Min về cô đắt à
Ok
Woa lại lắm thư mục cây thư mục thế cuốn
tóc lô đất sét gửi bố là vì thêu của
Please vào
Anh
đọc tin rồi xa
thư mục con chung một con sợ thật thế
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà vẫn thiếu và đẹp rồi à
thế này nó Tiffy luôn à
em ăn gì đấy à
ở Quản lý thông báo
Ừ thôi không chắc là tôi đã diện nhóm
mày với khoản thông báo cơ lại sợ có
thông báo gì đấy à
ở trường giang Suite các hư trong ghê
gớm thật axit Thuận luôn không dùng là
gj gì cả
anh nói này bắt đầu ở hơi bị nhiều việc
quá hơi say rồi Kim lại không không lại
đi xa quá
sự kiện mới kiểm tra đấy cũng ra đến cho
sự ổn nó còn rồi thiếu ở bên á khách
hàng thôi Nhưng Mày nhắm mày nhiều cái
nó hơi sai sai đấy Hỏi nhiều quá mà ban
man quá ơi
à à
A
Way Dương file bị khách hàng nghìn trống
dài dặc này Delete order sợ con đi order
gì đấy
Ê status tận status 7 liên hệ
Ừ ừ thì các bạn vẫn có thể xả đơn hàng
này có trong trường hợp đơn hàng đang xử
lý cũng là một ý hay được
để Wen hiệu của Samurai đi sáng này cũng
khá rồi được
thì lộ hết Có rồi lỗi hết rồi nhóm khác
tham khảo chứ
Em
xin lỗi nha
cho thằng khác không đi đâu đang có bảo
73 ông em ạ
Ừ nhưng mà chắc nghĩ mày ông kia đang
đang tập trung nghe đang đang làm đồ án
hoặc đang gì gì đâu hãy kệ đi à
à à
a
3 bếp thiếu ba đất Na special
à à
ừ ừ
anh
ngắm anh chiều ba đứa rồi à
ở các ơn
con cá sấu phù hiệu Castle là gì thư mục
chấm a
anh
nghe nhưng mà không hiểu tôi nói gì
không
nói thế vài đứa rồi
nhỉ Làm nhiều phết I
à à
xe khách hàng công tắc luôn cũng được
a single shop
ăn tối ở mới để ý những cái file lạ của
các bạn đấy lauxanh Ok rồi
see more in grizzlies Steel là tên hơi
gì ạ
à Xong rồi size after
a sinister sim Size Size of sẽ tới cái
gì
em chưa nghe dở cái nón đang càng Nội sẽ
chính tả chữa chứ không không có tư này
trong từ điển
em
có bạn xếp đây
A
gọi trong xin chữ gì
Tại sao tận hai đầu này thế Sẽ được thôi
tôi chưa biết của vụ này đấy
Ừ
Kệ cứ cho bên cái hàng còn đi em đi làm
sao
anh đi lên này Xóa thẳng luôn ok
cho hợp lý thiết kế xóa bén amin chưa ra
đây thì cả rồi hiểu nhá
ở
ngã tư
à à
3 nốt năm cuối năm
ở ngoài dài
khi chia tay chưa thua mục cửa này nó
sao lại thế
từ chiều giờ mục kiểu ở không tổng tất
cả những thằng này danh mục vào trong
thư mục mà tổng
mấy kiểu thư mục con fix hai à cấu hình
gì liệu website
ở nước ta là gì đấy à Ý bạn này xài boss
spa hoặc cả
nv3 thế
Lý Nhã Kỳ thực
không sao không ạ Các bạn kiểu mới này
vì sao phải có những cái từ tiếng Anh
chuyên ngành không hẳn là chuyên ngành
của bên công nghệ thông tin nữa nó tiếng
Anh cậu tên gọi của nói thử
ông gửi anh ở Việt đã cũng được
Ừ cũng được chơi Chuyên tiếng Anh mà
người anh rể Việt không sao cả
Ừ thế này có phải chiếu và đến bữa ăn
Min à Đúng nhỉ
Ý tôi là tôi nói tôi kiểm tra Bất Chợt
Một pha đó mà dài thiếu của tôi cho là
thiếu ấy Em yêu đừng oán trách Thôi cái
hàng khi hàng 1A
I Fall In xơ Tự Do khách hàng của Ford
Miss gì đây
khi vóc Days update sản phẩm
xe
khách hàng tự Đăng Mạnh tự đang bán cho
tụi tao mua
Các bạn ơi
sản xuất sai
gì sai không khổ chặn cháy hiểu mày tới
từ tiếng Anh mời bạn lại đặt
anh Anh Sai Rồi
Ừ ông ấy làm thu khách hàng Tính ơi
anh em thời sửa lại nhé sửa lại nhé ok
đại thành những nhóm bên kia
em
có nhiều nhóm khác nổi mà không thấy có
nhiều nhóm thì cần phải chỉnh nhưng mà
hồng như là các nhóm đều cũng tôi cũng
góp ý ở đây đúng ạ mấy ông mấy ông có gì
xem lại xem tôi có bí từng nhóm nhà nhá
mấy nhóm dưới này nhóm đợt 2 vẫn phản
động hôm trước thiếu thì tôi chưa chưa
xem để mà chấm sẽ lại sau ừ thế tôi phải
đánh dấu lại thôi quên Nội Tôi ở nhà
kiểu gì cũng phải xem lại hết tất cả
nhóm hàng riêng từng nhóm sao thì cậu
không nhớ nhiều nhóm đang tiến độ là
tiến độ chậm hơn nhóm khác nhiều nhóm
còn tạo xong làm khác mà không biết được
ở các bộ Hôm nay cha tạ thế thôi nhỉ
Ừ mạng tâm sự rất nhiều rồi các bạn còn
muốn tâm sự gì nữa thì nhắn tin đi mẫu
riêng hoặc à bình luận sau nhé tạm nghỉ
Hôm nay thôi
Xin chào bạn nhé
ừ ừ